even though total war warhammer 3
features some of the more niche factions
in games workshop's old world it makes
it all the more impressive that creative
assembly have managed to make the third
entry into this trilogy the largest and
most dynamic as game sports resident
warhammer nerd i got to play a few hours
with a preview build of total war
warhammer 3. specifically the campaigns
of grand cafe and the newly announced
pick and mix of demons chaos undivided
and while the other races of
kisslevite's demons and ogres were
unplayable they certainly made their
presence known on the battlefield with
the addition of chaos undivided that
brings the number of playable races at
launch up to eight those being nurgle
slaanesh zinch korn chaos undivided
kislev the ogre kingdoms and grand
cathay no matter the choice however it
appears that each faction's story will
see them heading to the realms of chaos
themselves creative assembly have stated
that this game's map is twice the size
as the previous entry and the home of
each chaos god will certainly help make
up a portion of that as the story
progresses rifts will open up in the
world allowing you to enter a realm of
your choosing each with its own unique
challenges and gameplay nurgle is full
of disease and players must find
resistances and cures before they lose
armies to attrition corn will only allow
you to delve deeper into his domain
after spilling enough blood zinc's realm
is made of riddles and you must choose
the correct teleporter runes to delve
deeper into the realm and slaanesh is
based around challenging descents
through circles of depravity each god
will also tempt you with rewards of
items resistances currency alliances
with chaotic forces and more however the
trade-off is a permanent negative trait
tied to your character so it'll be up to
you to choose whether or not these boons
are worth the price you pay but it is
only at the center of these realms that
you will face the new challenging final
survival battles of the particular chaos
god you are of course competing with
every other faction too so it's more
than likely that you'll encounter armies
from across the campaign here in the
realms of chaos be they friend or foe
cathay was the first faction i chose to
play as as i was intrigued to see how
creative assembly could build a faction
that previously only existed as snippets
of lore within the warhammer fantasy
books these dragon defenders of the
great bastion share their starting point
with a great wall separating themselves
from a never-ending tide of chaos
invasion this defensive element to their
start and their law is mirrored in the
units that they can field but with it
comes one key element that is unique to
their forces harmony and balance is a
core feature to grand cathay and nearly
every facet of their economy buildings
research and army reflect either an
element of yin or yang in the world map
keeping harmony will grant buffs to
things like growth and public order
whereas being too heavily weighted in
either direction will cause
destabilization this essence of harmony
can also affect your units in battle
with each also having an element to yin
or yank ensuring units of opposite
alignment are close together during
battles will boost their stats and make
them all the more capable in combat this
extra level of strategy is minor but
it's a great feeling when you combine
units to become a balanced and
harmonious force that is more than the
sum of their parts grand cathay also has
a few features that play into unique
mechanics as well as their lore and map
location their wushing compass allows
them to alter the winds of magic across
their lands allowing you to set up buffs
and bonuses for future battles or make
life that little bit harder for the
enemies beyond your walls and the
location of the ivory road means that
cathay and forces can send trade
caravans westward to the old world and
the further you send them the better the
profit but beware as both dilemmas and
rewards exist on these trails these
caravans work much like generals or be
it ones that you won't control directly
in the world map instead you'll set them
off on their journey and they'll
periodically check in on you if anything
comes up during their travels it could
be anything from an empire captain
looking for work to ogres looking to you
as their next meal triggering a battle
and giving you the option to command
directly these events are great as they
allow you to feel like you have more
control over the fate of your caravans
and engaging with them often grants you
a little extra reward beyond the payday
of goods delivered
[Music]
now we were only made aware of the chaos
undivided faction at the start of our
hands-on with the game and while i'm
usually a stalwart follower of the
plague father i was very excited for the
ability to control an army of demons
from every god under the banner of a
single demon prince the main drive for
this faction is glory every time you win
a battle or take a settlement you have
the ability to dedicate this victory or
milestone to a chaos god and doing so
will grant you specific boons units and
even body parts the deeper your
dedication the bigger the rewards you
can opt in to diversify your favors and
as such get a little something from
every god to keep your arsenal and
roster diverse or you can choose to hone
in on a specific god and play style and
rush towards their more juicy rewards
and of course as you are indeed playing
as a demon prince these rewards can also
manifest physically nurgle could bless
you with wings corn a fiery armored
chest zinch the head of an avian beast
and slaanesh a tooth laden tail all of
these change the benefits your demon
prince brings to your game with many of
them offering unique abilities and
spells different fighting styles or just
beefing up the unit's health and armor
naturally you can also change these as
you see fit and on the fly meaning that
you can swap out the bits and pieces of
your own mortal form at will experiment
with builds and combinations from
different gods or fully devote your
flesh prison to the entity of your
choosing seeing the swathe of garish
colours in hellish forms taking the
field of battle after i'd ingratiated
myself with a selection of the warhammer
gods was equal parts magnificent and
hilarious but did also drive home that
emphasis of player choice
additional options for players seem to
have been a core goal throughout the
development of creative assembly's third
entry into the world of warhammer many
of the improvements and changes that the
team have made having quality of life
improvements as well as new or tweaked
features enhanced diplomacy opens up
better war coordination as well as the
option to pay for outposts to be built
in friendly allied territories which
will allow you to recruit a unit or two
from their roster battles have also had
some big changes in particular siege and
settlement battles for the unwarded
variety many of them are now able to be
assaulted from every angle these 360
degree balances of attack and defense
open up new strategic opportunities and
avenues of attack when it comes to the
walled in cities however changes to
sieges mean that there are more options
for defenders beyond garrison their
walls should the fight take to the
streets the defender has the option to
use total war warhammer 3's new supply
system letting generals throw up
defending towers or barricades to either
force fights into specific kill zones or
ensure the attacking force has to
dedicate resources into taking them down
previously siege battles would feel
pretty stale with the only option
seeming to be defend the wall or abandon
them entirely but now there are many
more options available to the defenders
this has had to be balanced for the
attacker however as attackers face enemy
units breach walls or take objectives
they will earn momentum giving them
buffs to their units to help counteract
any traps towers or barricades in the
short time i got to play i felt both
these elements working in tandem made
siege battles a much more strategic and
engaging affair there would be times
where i'd willingly give up a wall or
corner of my city because i knew i'd
built up enough supplies to make an even
stronger backline with troops already
awaiting me and as the attacker i felt a
drive to continue pushes and pincer
attacks knowing that my units were much
more stalwart driven on by the morale
boosts of each little victory through
breaches and objectives now we can hope
that these changes will be retroactively
applied to the previous games or at
least to their larger combined campaign
map but as of yet when we are going to
see that arrive in warhammer 3 has not
been confirmed although when i did speak
to some members of the team they did say
that post launch support will be similar
to what we've come to expect of this
franchise and that sometime down the
line a grand campaign and a suite of dlc
will be coming so something to be extra
excited about even beyond the launch of
total war warhammer 3 on the 17th of
february now i do have a gameplay video
ready for you right now showing off a
bit of my time with chaos undivided but
other than that i think that's all i've
got for you if you have more questions
you can feel free to throw them down
below or tweet me at regular dave and i
will do my best to answer them otherwise
i hope you enjoyed this little preview
of total war warhammer 3 make sure you
subscribe and i'll see you next time
[Music]
so
[Music]
you